[Musique]
c'est ben tu as vu il a repris du poids
et il a retrouvé sa petite étincelle
dans les yeux ça se voit il va beaucoup
mieux alors pourquoi tu caches tout nos
affaires on avait dit qu'on revit
devrait pas ça tu te souviens tu as une
journée demain à cette heure si tu
regardes désintox
je ne quitterai pas des yeux une seconde
c'est clair c'est bien rentrer à la
maison
si tu me connaissait vraiment tu
voudrais plus jamais me voir non non
maman tu ne connais pas tout ce que je
veux c'est que tu fasses un dernier
petit truc pour moi
[Musique]
à
ce cesse mon fils l'homme ayant pas il
faut que tu rentres à la maison non pas
son band
retrouvez mon fils est gay
tout ce que je me suis infligé à moi et
aux autres peut pas les sauver mais tu
t'en voudra toute ta vie qui ne sais pas
ou est ce que tu veux que je t'en terre
dix mois d'attenté
à mourir
enfin bref voilà je suis toujours là
alors merci à tous merci pour
c
ainsi que ce soit
[Musique]